NOW THIS, THIS RACHEL DOLEZAL
SITUATION HAS A HUGE RESPONSE
EVERYWHERE.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW THE BLACK
COMMUNITY FEELS ABOUT IT.
LET'S CHECK IN WITH OUR BLACK
EMERGENCY TECHNICIAN ROBIN
THEDE. ROBIN, YOU'RE AT
HEADQUARTERS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LARRY.
Larry: WHICH HEADQUARTERS?
>> BLACK HEADQUARTERS.
Larry: OH.
>> I'M FREAKING OUT, LARRY THIS.
IS A MAJOR BLACK SECURITY
BREACH.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: UMMM, A BLACK SECURITY
BREECH?
>> RACHEL DOLEZAL CRACKED THE
HOLY GRAIL OF BLACK SECRETS.
BLACK WOMENS HAIR.
>> Larry: REALLY, BLACK WOMENS
HAIR.
>> YES.
IT'S EVEN SECRET TO BLACK MEN.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
>> Larry: TRUE.
>> THEY JUST KNOW NOT TO TOUCH
IT.
>> Larry: THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S TRUE.
I LEAVE IT ALONE.
I DON'T MESS WITH IT.
>> VERY SMART.
VERY SMART STRATEGY LARRY.
YET THIS WHITE WOMEN HAS
MASTERED EVERY BLACK WOMEN HAIR
LOOK.
THE CURLY MIX GIRL LOOK.
THE 16 HOUR MICRO BRAID.
>> Larry: I HAD NO IDEA.
>> AND THE LOCS DOWN TO HER
BOOTY.
SHE RISKED HER EDGES FOR THE
LOCS, LARRY.
HER EDGES.
>> Larry: I GET IT, ROBIN.
>> HOLD ON, ROBIN.
YOU HAVE IT ALL WRONG.
RACHEL DOLEZAL ISN'T A DANGER.
SHE'S A PIONEER.
>> Larry: HEY, IT'S MIKE YARD.
EVERYBODY.
IT'S MIKE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
OKAY.
WAIT HOW IS SHE A PIONEER, MIKE?
>> A BLACK CONVERT, LARRY.
Larry: CONVERT?
WAIT A SECOND ARE YOU IN A
CHURCH?
>> INDEED I AM.
LARRY, RELIGIONS HAVE BEEN
GROWING NUMBERS WITH CONVERTS
FOR CENTURIES, LAYERY . IT'S
TIME FOR US TO GET IN ON THE
ACTION, BROTHER.
>> Larry: WHITE, MIKE.
WHY DO BLACKS NEED CONVERTS.
>> I'M TIRED OF BEING THE
MINORITY.
LET'S BE THE MAJORITY.
RACHEL DOLEZAL PUT IN A LOT OF
LEG WORK FOR BLACK PEOPLE
SHE TAUGHT AFRICAN-AMERICAN
STUDIES, RAISED BLACK CHILDREN,
WORKS FOR THE NAACP.
I HAVEN'T DONE THAT.
WE CAN'T JUST SHIP HER BACK.
I HAVE BEEN BLACK MY WHOLE LIFE,
NEVER DID IT.
>> Larry: WAIT, SHIP HER BACK?
WHAT ARE YOU SUGGESTING, MIKE?
>> I SUGGEST A PATH TO BLACK
CITIZENSHIP, LARRY.
>> Larry: OKAY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Larry: BLACK CITIZENSHIP?
>> YES, LARRY.
SHE GAVE UP THE LIFE OF A WHITE
WOMEN TO LIVE THE LIFE OF A
BLACK WOMAN.
DO YOU KNOW THE SACRIFICE?
>> Larry: I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
THAT.
>> LARRY, POLICE GO LOOKING FOR
MISSING WHITE WOMEN.
I THINK WE SHOULD WELCOME HER
WITH OPEN ARMS.
>> Larry: MAYBE YOU'RE RIGHT.
MAYBE SHE DIDN'T THINK THIS
THROUGH.
>> I'M NOT WELCOMING A DAMN
THING, LARRY!
THIS IS A CONSPIRACY.
WHITE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HIDING
FOR YEARS!
>> Larry: IT'S HOLLY WALKER,
EVERYBODY.
HOLLY, WHERE ARE YOU?
>> IN THE WOODS.
Larry: OKAY.
SO, WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
CONSPIRACY?
>> FAKE BLACK PEOPLE ARE
EVERYWHERE, LARRY!
I HAVE BEEN HUNTING THEM MY
WHOLE ADULT LIFE.
I CALL THEM INCOG-NEGROS.
>> Larry: WAIT A SECOND.
INCOG-NEGROS.
>> YES INCOG-NEGROS.
AND RACHEL DOLEZAL IS THE TIP OF
THE INCOG-NEGRO ICEBERG.
HERE IS FOOTAGE I HAVE OF ONE 15
YEARS AGO.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: WAIT, WAIT.
HOLD ON.
NO, NO.
WAIT.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: I THINK THAT'S JUST A
WHITE WOMAN WITH A FRO.
>> YOU'RE JUST BRAINWASHED.
Larry: I'M NOT.
>> THEY'RE IN OUR NAIL SALONS
AND CHURCHES.
I SAW A INCOG-NEGRO AT A
JUNETEENTH COOKOUT THIS WEEKEND.
I SAID YOU'RE NOT FOOLING
ANYBODY.
WHO BRINGS PIZZA BAGELS TO A
JUNETEENTH COOKOUT?
A INCOG-NEGRO.
>> WHO CARES ABOUT THIS.
WE NEED TO BE INCLUSIVE.
>> NO, LARRY, WE NEED TO KEEP
EVERYONE OUT.
>> COME TO THINK OF IT LARRY,
YOU'RE LOOKING A LITTLE PALE
YOURSELF.
>> Larry: NO, NO, NO.
>> LISTEN, ANSWER THIS.
WHEN YOUR PARENTS DISCIPLINED
YOU, DID YOU GET A TALKING TO OR
A WHOOPING?
>> Larry: THIS IS NOT ABOUT ME,
COME ON.
>> LARRY, DON'T TELL YOUR
SECRETS.
>> LARRY CAN BE BLACK IF HE
WANTS.
TO.
>> Larry: I AM BLACK.
>> A INCOG-NEGRO.
Larry: I'M NOT INCOG-NEGRO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.